here's my situation I live here with
these people
I Drive this I'm not your typical
Porsche customer but Porsche has a
family-friendly car in its lineup so I
went to check it out here on the Angeles
Crest Highway in Southern California
where Porsches arranged a long drive to
a racetrack called Willow Springs
one question you may have another car
like an economist who is it we know the
Porsches before they were pert mostly
management wanted sports cars horse
really likes to talk about the DNA
that's in all of their vehicles how
there's a strong family resemblance
personally I happen to think that every
car they make seems to want to keep
looking like a 911 even though it's lost
that purpose altogether the rear of the
car in my opinion is the most successful
part of the exterior design it's so
sleek you might wonder where's the
handle to open up the rear hatch and
Porsche is very cleverly put a button
right here push that voila
you'd expect the portion to handle well
yeah this car does four-wheel-drive is
not just good for traction it also can
be good from handling it makes the car
what they like to call neutral
everything motive is moving in a very
predictable safe and reassuring quest
yeah of course turbo has a speed of a
hundred sixty-four miles per hour and
that's great but who's ever gonna get up
to 164 miles per hour a lot of carmakers
have a test just like this one where you
climb to a top of a mountain and the
fact of the matter is probably nobody's
gonna take thermicon to the top of a
mountain and furthermore most probably
knows that but what they're selling is
the security
so has Porsche created one of the best
compact SUVs on the market probably is
it really meant to scale mountaintops
and run on racetracks of course not if
you want to see makan in its true
natural habitat come here